dave is with us in Ohio hi Dave how are
you Nene Ramsey good to talk to you sir
you too man what's up hey okay so here's
what I want to do I work at a church
about 26 28 miles from my house I've got
a Honda minivan we have all old cars we
don't have very I mean I want to try we
have about because of you and your
program at about 3,000 dollars worth of
debt that were that we're gonna be done
with soon here so but what I want to do
is and I'll bet I could talk you into it
is I spend about 160 bucks in gas a
month no one to and from work I'd like
to I don't have the cash to do it but
I'd like to borrow $5,000 to get a
Toyota Prius and cut my gas payment in
half basically $5,000 would be about a
hundred dollars a month and I'm saving
$80 a month in gas so that means I'm
paying 20 bucks a month for my car what
do you think I've never in 30 years told
someone to borrow money to buy a car and
I'm certainly not going to start today
no it does not make sense because the
Prius is going to have higher
maintenance and higher insurance than
the car you've got now and so your
analysis is leaving out a whole bunch of
numbers and you're going to end up
losing money on this transaction when
it's all said and done plus the Prius is
more expensive and it's gonna go down in
value more than the car you've got so no
a used one I know but they'll go down in
value more in the car you've got so I
don't mind you a better car it sounds
like you need to get a better car what's
your car worth I probably about I don't
know four or five at 2,700 I see it's
worth four or five thousand dollars yeah
what you're getting a $5,000 Prius
you're getting a $10,000 free issue
matter right why what's happening to the
villain
the very go on to my daughter oh okay so
you're borrowing money so you can give
your daughter a car okay
whatever yeah I'm definitely borrowing
money that's what I'm trying to say but
I'm spending the 20 bucks a month on the
honor on a Prius rather than there's a
better a better idea okay how does your
daughter all right
she's 17 okay good I think she needs to
partner up and save up and buy her a
self a beater and I think you take your
$5,000 van and sell it and buy a $5,000
Prius and now you don't have a car
payment but you got a teenager that
doesn't have a car
oh well we can work that through